hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
au.l2-3.3.2 ensure that the actions of
individual system users can be uniquely
traced to those users so they can be
held accountable for their action it's
going to put you in handcuffs baby
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance solution where we can
help you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so
cmmccontrol
au.l1-3.3.2 ensure that the actions of
individual system users can be uniquely
traced to those users so they can be
held accountable for their actions why
is it so critical for so many reasons
but most importantly we have to be able
to know who did what when in order to
adequately secure our systems right
because if we don't know who did it or
at least what account did it how we know
what really was going down again I'm not
going to go extensively into the cyber
security reasoning behind this if you
want more information reach out to us uh
there's links below links in the bio and
we can obviously help walk you through
things things but for the sake of
understanding what the assessors really
care about I think on this one let's
just jump into what the assessors are
looking for how to make them happy now
two control points here all right
determine if the content of the audit
records needed to support the ability to
uniquely Trace users to their actions is
defined uh and we would say of course it
is right because it's basically built
into our seam Solution that's what a
seam solution does uh and again you'll
probably be expected to give some sort
of a demonstration
second Point determine if audit records
once created contain the defined content
implemented via the same solution so
again determine if audit records once
created contain the defined content show
that again uh it's all there right in
the same solution not really a lot more
to it you're probably giving a
demonstration on this one in order to
actually prove your case so at on-call
we work with defense contractors just
like you who have had this defars nist
itar and cmmc compliance stuff dropped
in their laps like a seagull on a sunny
day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance earns
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments below to let
us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign